there's a monster under my bed almost
every parent has heard their kids make
the claim and it's usually nothing more
than some unusual shadows or at worst a
household pest scurrying around parents
usually tell their child to go back to
sleep or maybe try to dispel their fears
by shining a light under the bed it's a
childhood rite of passage and one that
usually passes soon enough but for one
young woman in missouri the monster
under her bed was very real and very
dangerous
scp-3887-a doesn't seem like she belongs
in a containment facility she's a
24-year-old woman who lived a quiet life
in her hometown until things went
horribly wrong she doesn't appear to
possess any special abilities and the
foundation is able to contain her
without any difficulty but wherever she
goes
death and destruction follow it's not
her doing but there is something out
there that will not stand to see her
hurt in any way her personal monster
under the bed is very protective
something another young woman found out
the hard way incident
3887-8-1 occurred in 2014
when the young woman was attending a
party with her girlfriend her partner
was berating and humiliating her in
front of the guests which was apparently
not a rare occurrence in their
relationship suddenly something
manifested under a nearby table and
before she could react her girlfriend
was brutally mauled by the unknown
creature her limbs were completely
severed from her body and she died at
the scene an undercover scp agent who
was implanted within the local
authorities made their way to the scene
as soon as possible and found scp-3887-a
in a state of shock and who could blame
her after the encounter she just had
with what would become to be known as
scp-3887-b
while
3887-a is a normal human with no unusual
abilities or characteristics
3887-b is anything but foundation
scientists have described it as a
humanoid entity standing over seven feet
tall its skin is greenish gray and it
has two long sharp horns on its head its
head and neck are covered in thick black
hair and its eyes are a striking yellow
color its mouth is full of sharp fang
similar to that of a shark and its
elongated arms allow it to move on all
fours it has a long hairless tail that
resembles a rats and possesses both male
and female reproductive organs no one
knows where it came from but they do
have an idea why it's sticking around
scp-38
seems to be bonded to scp-3887-a
and can appear in any darkened area
within a 5-meter radius around her while
its favorite location is under
3887-a's bed which has since been
brought to the facility it appears to be
able to teleport wherever she is
just as it did during the party where it
made its presence brutally clear it has
odd eating patterns and is able to gain
nourishment from practically any object
whether resembles what we would consider
food or not its favorite treats for
example scp-3887-a's
socks but it does have one weakness that
has been useful in containing it it
can't stand the light and it doesn't
just hate it when
scp-3887-b is exposed to bright light it
develops blisters and wounds and flees
to the nearest dark area scp foundation
scientists are at a loss to explain
exactly what this creature is though and
scp-3887-b seems to be a chimera of
multiple animals with multiple types of
dna it possesses dna similar to humans
but also from a type of oryx with
similar horns as well as a rat with the
same type of tail as well as a common
cane toad and there's even some dna that
doesn't resemble any creature in nature
studying it further has been trickier
though because it seems to have the
effect of disrupting any electronic
recording devices near it causing
lasting damage if it's in proximity to
them for too long there has been one
good bit of news for scp scientists
though because while it has shown that
it can be extremely violent it has not
attacked foundation officials not yet at
least its good behavior may not have
anything to do with how it personally
feels about foundation's staff though
and is instead all thanks to scp-3887-a
3887-a has been completely cooperative
since she was taken into custody by the
foundation she doesn't perceive them as
a threat and so far it seems like
scp-3887-b
is following her lead it has a strong
emotional connection to the young woman
and when they're alone they show
affectionate behavior towards each other
while the creature does not seem to like
the foundation it doesn't seem like it
wants to become hostile until the
foundation gives it a reason to when
3887-a was interviewed following the
tragic incident by undercover foundation
agent bellamy she was panicked and
terrified she admitted that her partner
often treated her badly and believed
that the creature was trying to protect
her she admitted that she had seen the
creature before she even had a name for
it she called her grenda 3887-a
thought she was crazy now there was
proof though she was not imagining the
monster under her bed describing grenda
as her boogeyman the young woman talked
about how she had known the creature
since she was a child she grew up in an
old house in the country that was full
of strange sounds that made it sound
like something was in her room with her
and sometimes she would even catch a
glimpse of what she thought was a
monster under her bed watching her she
tried telling her parents but they
thought she was making the whole thing
up and even she was forced to wonder if
she was hallucinating or had somehow
imagined the whole thing but then when
she was a teenager all of her doubts
were put to bed one night 38 87-8
parents were loudly fighting a sadly not
rare occurrence in their household and
she locked herself in her room to get
away from them as she hid grenda emerged
from under her bed for the first time
and talked with her and she isn't the
only one that grenda is willing to speak
with she's also sat down for her own
interviews with foundation researchers
well the researchers sat down while
grenda remained under the bed foundation
researcher dr tanner interviewed grenda
who was cordial but guarded and remained
deeply protective of the girl under her
protection she expressed feeling guilty
for getting
3887-a in trouble but dr tanner assured
her that
3887-8 was not being punished and was
being kept at the foundation for her own
safety he offered that they could keep
grenda safe as well but she responded
that as long as
3887-8 remains safe then she would be as
well she explained that her kind fed on
the anxiety of children which was why
they lurked under their beds she was
apparently only supposed to remain with
this girl until she was 10 or so but
became attached and decided to stay with
her which was against the rules of her
people and as a result she had been
exiled from her home at this point
grenda offered to show herself to the
researcher and began to emerge from
under the bed unfortunately as has
become standard when attempting to
document scp-3887-b
all of the recording equipment
malfunctioned and was unable to record
grenda's appearance the foundation
continued to have questions about this
pair and their strange relationship and
interviewed
scp-3887-a again
this time by a dr garden
3887-8 told dr garden that she had been
sleeping well and had been spending lots
of time talking to the entity under her
bed that led dr garden to bring up a
theory about how scp-3887-b
had come to exist the young woman
speculated that grenda may have been
created from her fears one of her first
memories of being scared was when she
went to an aquarium and a massive bull
shark came close to the glass where it
bared its rows and rows of shark teeth
the exact same kind of teeth that grenda
possessed in fact all the traits grenda
exhibited like a rat tail seemed to
connect to childhood fears that she had
experienced
3887-8 always felt alone as a little
girl and she believed that she might
have manifested granda as a companion
who was there exactly when she needed
her to be this raised the question of
whether
scp-3887-b really was the unnatural
entity or if
scp-3887-a is the source of the entity's
existence the next interview with
scp-3880
would raise even more questions when dr
garden went to interview scp-3887-b
it was clear that the entity was
agitated grenda became hostile as soon
as dr garden entered the room saying she
was hungry and didn't want to answer
questions when dr garden said that
3887-8 had provided it with socks the
entity reacted with anger the socks were
just a snack to live it needed fear
3887-b
fed off human emotions specifically
paranoia and anxiety
scp-3887-a used to be full of them but
now she was unusually calm in the
facility and it was having a bad effect
on her companion when dr garden promised
to talk to supervisors the creature
became more agitated and reached out
from under the bed grabbing dr garden
and pulling her under the bed no one
knew what would happen to dr garden
under the bed and
scp-3887-a was quickly summoned to try
to calm her companion down but when she
called for grunda there was no response
it was feared that dr garden had been
lost to the area under the bed that no
one can access but then 13 minutes later
the doctor suddenly emerged from under
the bed she was bruised soaking wet and
missing articles including shoes socks
and her glasses
later interviews with dr garden would
give the best picture yet of where
scp-3887-b
comes from dr garden described being
pulled under the bed which then led
somewhere else entirely she fell for 15
seconds still being held by scp-3887-b
but when she landed she was alone in a
large cave made of black rock with
purple gems in the walls the cave
contained a waterfall a lake and what
looked like
scp-3887's secret home it was filled
with pictures of the girl she was bonded
to a violin some stuffed animals and
large piles of the girl's socks
scp-3887-b
was there in the cave with her too
watching her she would catch glimpses of
the creature her white fangs and her
yellow eyes she was terrified and ran
screaming trying to find any way out of
there as the creature pursued her she
couldn't evade her forever though and
eventually grenda grabbed dr garden she
was lifted into the air as grenda bared
her shark-like teeth but instead of
eating her the creature instead took off
the doctor's socks and thanked her
before somehow sending her back up into
the darkness she then found herself back
under the bed surrounded by worried scp
personnel since then
scp-3887-b has not brought anyone else
into its home it seems feeding on dr
garden's fear was enough for the time
being and the situation has remained
stable since the scp foundation has been
able to develop relatively simple
containment procedures for the two
entities that make up scp-3887
as neither is currently hostile the two
are contained within a standard humanoid
containment cell with the bed at the
center
scp-3887-a is given standard amenities a
healthy diet including a vitamin for
some minor health issues and her own
control over the lights in the cell she
has requested and been given a gaming
system for entertainment and up-to-date
entertainment media but was denied
access to the internet a pet cat and
access to the on-site recreation areas
due to the risk of scp-3887-b
getting loose the facility does have
plans in place in case grenda decides to
become hostile again though while
scp-3887-a
normally maintains control of the lights
in her cell the foundation has a
failsafe installed so they can turn them
up at any time since
scp-3887
reacts negatively to bright light the
lights can be used as a security system
to send her retreating back under the
bed until she can be pacified through
other measures while neither of the
scp-3887 entities appears to be seeking
to escape it is impossible to predict
where and how
3887-b would act if
3887-a was free from her cell again and
whether she would attempt to harm those
she perceives as a threat to
3887-a as she did in the past so for now
the foundation is focused on keeping
both of them pacified which in the case
of
3887-b means a healthy supply of socks
but there's one other lingering question
the foundation hasn't solved scp-3887-b
referenced being exiled from its kin for
breaking the rules and was confined to a
cave that means there might be others
like grenda out there and they may be
more aggressive and less scrupulous than
she is while no other specimens have
been found the scp foundation will be
keeping a careful eye on any reports of
monsters lurking under children's beds
they might just be
telling the truth now for another entity
that lurks in a seemingly bottomless pit
check out
scp-354 the red pool or watch this video
instead